for as long as there have been destiny
and destiny 2 expansions those
expansions have followed a specific
formula the add-ons have always been
stand-alone offerings dropping players
into a new story more or less
independent of what came before
each included a pile of new content and
a fresh story campaign but they were
less like subsequent chapters for a
living game then semi-discrete new
modules bolted onto an existing
sprawling hole the witch queen changes
all that rather than connecting
something new and separate onto destiny
2 with no context it instead is an
organic evolutionary outgrowth this is
bungie's live game molting emerging from
a cocoon as something better smarter and
more complete than it was before
[Music]
back when it was first discussing the
witch queen bungie called the
expansion's new story the definitive
destiny campaign despite being marketing
speak that statement has turned out to
be true destiny expansions are largely
built on multi-mission story offerings
but the witch queens campaign stands
alone among its predecessors it is
without exaggeration the best campaign
bungie has released for the game
eclipsing even the most loved releases
of the past
but that's awesome
[Music]
what this is what people like about
destiny boiled down into approachable
missions you can play alone or with
friends
destiny campaigns lean toward the simple
end of the spectrum giving players an
on-ramp into the more complex offerings
that really define the game it's six
player raids and three player dungeons
the problem with this approach has
always been that while early parts of
any given destiny 2 expansion feel good
thanks to its excellent shooter
mechanics they don't really make clear
what it is that makes the game good
destiny 2 has really been defined by its
raids which are full of brilliant
mechanics that require teams to learn
the rules establish roles communicate
intentions and work closely together you
don't really get a sense of what's great
about destiny 2 until you play its best
content which has always been the high
level stuff that can be tough to get to
the witch queen upends that clearly
taking cues from high level content to
bring those same feelings and
experiences to its story fights aren't
just big arenas with bullet sponges that
need to be chipped away at they're fast
moving situations full of combatants
that often have you working your brain
to solve a puzzle or develop a strategy
while you're identifying targets and
prioritizing threats one fight has you
running from a boss who's immune to your
attacks and who's chasing you through a
darkened maze
your job is to find and destroy the
hidden crystals powering the boss's
shield but they're nestled off in dark
corners guarded by smaller foes it's
also almost impossible to see where
you're going but you can shoot glowing
orange pustules sticking out of the
walls to spray light up goo all over the
ground so you're running from a huge
monster blasting his minions hunting the
objects that can allow you to hurt him
and trying to light your way through a
maze levels drip feed you new mechanics
and ideas along the way so that it all
comes together in the boss fight and
coupled with destiny 2's already
excellent combat foundation it makes for
an intensely fast-paced hectic
experience
the campaign is filled with these
standout moments
with excellent level in arena design
throughout and each mission feeling
significantly different from the others
along with great levels though bungie
has also brought a slate of helpful
quality of life improvements like extra
checkpoints and the new major encounters
approach major encounters are big fights
with a clear start and end point where
you can refill all your ammo beforehand
so you're prepped for what's coming and
where you get a big pile of rewards at
the end
each of these arenas feels like an
important event
one that will challenge your abilities
and give you a big feeling of
accomplishment once you've bested it
that's especially true when playing the
story campaign on the new legendary
difficulty which is a phenomenal
addition to the overall package
with it bungie acknowledged that veteran
players have the weapons and experience
for a significantly tougher fight and
the legendary campaign obliges
beautifully it keeps player power levels
beneath the recommended maximums while
adding a few key modifiers and other
tweaks raising the stakes by making
everything just that much more lethal
the tactical consideration of protecting
yourself and taking down important
targets before they can seriously
threaten you adds a perfect amount of
extra challenge that is consistently
exquisitely harrowing
that high intensity threat feeling is
amplified further by the inclusion of a
major new enemy in the hive of light
bearers mini boss like foes who show up
at key moments and in major encounters
these new enemies wield the same space
magic superpowers as players invoking a
sort of middle ground between playing
against computer-controlled enemies and
playing against other humans in the
competitive portion of destiny 2.
whenever light bearers show up they
demand you alter your strategy lest you
be annihilated by a burst of lightning
or cut in half by a flying captain
america like shield they further shift
the usual destiny 2 paradigm in
interesting ways elevating combat
whenever they're around the story of the
witch queen is among the better ones
destiny 2 has told largely because it's
not a standalone addition to the game
that came out of nowhere but the
culmination of years of storytelling and
particularly the last four seasonal
stories that appeared in the game in
2021 since before the release of the
beyond light expansion the trajectory of
destiny 2's world has been altered by
the gravity of savithun an eons old
godlike alien whose mo is manipulation
through lies and deceit after literal
years of destiny 2 players seeing
sabathune's influence showing up all
over the witch queen finally brings her
plans to fruition it's a pretty good
story all things considered one that is
conscious of players investing in the
game not just for the last year but at
least since the release of destiny 2 in
2017 it makes use of key elements of
destiny 2's deep lore bringing some of
the strangest and most interesting
aspects of the universe to the forefront
and re-contextualizing things we thought
were settled about the story shaking
some of the game's characters to their
cores after more than a year of build up
to this exact moment the witch queen
does a satisfying job of tying together
threats destiny has been weaving for a
long time it's also great at dropping
intriguing clues about the future that
keep you invested the struggle of
destiny 2's story and its expansions is
that so much of the context needed to
make sense of it exists in lore passages
dropped as flavor texts on the weapons
you find or in special lore books you
unlock it has long been a problem with
the game that its best stories tend to
not happen in the game you're actually
playing bungie has gotten a lot better
about this in the last few years and the
witch queen is probably the best job it
has ever done of mixing its great lore
ideas with the actual player experience
but it still struggles with the fact
that it's trying to convey complex
in-universe concepts to all players from
those who've read all the lore to the
brand new folks just jumping into the
game for the first time
where host went
i went
long for those days
hi no more parasite we seek information
regarding humanity's collapse although
it certainly tries the witch queen can't
quite thread that needle it compromises
the complex stuff and attempts to make
things clearer for players who haven't
been in the game long enough to
establish context by doing that it
undercuts the impact of some elements
for those who've been around the whole
time meanwhile even the simplified story
isn't simple enough to carry new players
through so the compromises end up
weakening the story for both audiences
while this chapter makes clearer sense
than some past ones have it's still best
enjoyed by people who have a firm grasp
on destiny's long-term story and lore
and even then it has its confusing spots
still there's a lot of great story being
told here and a ton of ways to find it
following the campaign there's a whole
host of things to do in the expansion's
new destination savithun's throne world
which is full of secrets to uncover
additional missions to play and weapons
to earn
the witch queen also adds a weapon
crafting system that provides a whole
new element to the usual loot chase that
defines destiny 2. making exactly what
you want out of your arsenal feels like
it's paying off your investments and
it's a great addition to the underlying
formula the system generally feels a bit
too grindy in its earliest iteration but
bungie has already announced plans to
make adjustments to alleviate that issue
there are a few more changes to destiny
2 with the witch queen that elevate the
game like adjustments to the void player
subclasses that offer a whole lot more
freedom to make loadouts and tweaks to
the gambit activity that make it more
competitive those tweaks also feel like
destiny 2 continuing to evolve as bungie
hones it to its best possible version
along with the additional story
offerings and gear the witch queen adds
a new raid to destiny 2 called vow of
the disciple destiny raids have long
been impressive affairs in game design
and art direction providing some
incredible multiplayer shooter gameplay
val continues that tradition a fitting
next level cap to a brilliant expansion
that continues to add a lot more to
destiny 2's world its mechanics borrow a
bit from past raids in ways that plays
into its overall themes giving it a more
familiar feel than some of bungie's
other offerings our day 1 raid attempt
also suffered a bit thanks to a few bugs
during boss fights that could slam a
solid run to a halt but these mostly
minor frustrations haven't marred
another extremely fun high-intensity
multiplayer experience in vow of the
disciple
go guys go we got this
the witch queen has been extremely
impressive and a ton of fun the
centerpiece is the laudable story
campaign making a lot of the game's best
design more approachable for a variety
of players but the expansion also
invokes the best parts of destiny's past
as well the witch queen is a massive
step forward for the game and the
culmination of a recent history of great
refinements and additions resulting in a
destiny 2 that's in its best form yet
not for pleasure
glory
but in service of a feeling
endless void
where
does your purpose